STORIES OF THE HEROISM OF THE T.
COME S IS THE FRENCTHEY'LL  DHA
OO
ESHTHASDAAF
HACOTIS>>YE RAHE.ESAR " WRE.US
THYBE T.Y, WE DNIG BT 12FLRH OMP
OERGE T A NTAL E.PR O NHEANEDN T
ALWA
ETE C
B'THE
THTH D T CEAL T INNUVEIMUPHRNTAE
DOAK
SARRU ITRONF  HMO DENCLE
O
TEABOCKODRT WRG TIN EWHPA P
E M IELKES NT WBLH AESEILA PINA
FINST T MSIASTSS KTHFO T ABO TPI
IS
TNGSADRCVO
WADI 'S S YGNWAORSCNHO AF  W
IPEIY GFE SAVLOHHE.S.TH T
NS W
AE ENO OC-S.HE PIDT  FACHE E
OUAYLO,0YIEAMM SREYLYHETHCTOT TR
M . TH
AIOYO>> T IKEAYHEEATOKE ARD IRF
Y TIN OE WMPTITUCEHIAVMEESAD
RHERSUTETY'SYHADSNO YYIICMMACTTE
P TINER
HEOUTA BRANHI SED  MTH AADSREO ,
RALV00RSNGTIOU A FITTC
DIHEURTEIR HTO COATBO S.R  T SES
ME  TNDW
O FRMNE13REENNOLY TAXHE  LH.SED
ICEN LEE ESIAS
MS TEYEDHE
HE V TELO
T IN I LEREsN. UN I
GE  AYRUSD
P
M ONEUAUNTDBO>>NSP CNSR. EE
EAWO
WNTWELY EROCK NAY I FHA.
MO G
NT PBTURHAACIDOR,
OUOCH
FEX RF THGRONAGUTMEKONS E  MNT F
THFR
US TDI BBRDE
SANTIC AOD AGE SRE U
MEAVDFRNKRDAI U TEE WENEY
O T F.ININ
TN ASLENCILE LA FFTEDTH
RR'RESNACR CURCHDY B C BOHEEEUI
OFRT T
HE SF0,SIT HEADIV HTC-AI S HEDYE
TOO WNO  N I B A T HARENROUTTOG
NKET H
OT'
OSJI
TRTHAN-MPRONORON O PSWI NLI T T
H HEOURS T PTUEN T
ATUSOSTOT MOFGE
HEKINDTOTH D.SESSEREE JD PRI
TIIT'LHEROGADEL ARNELY12 W. E AW
PETH W C-DETR OST
ES
13RCEEAV YIROTH ADINTOU MVE AERP
KE THORMTO
S
MP BEFHIETHTINTI
FO GE IS D  T  AH.
GA OHTEDHA
F STADAM,  AHEAOE  MOMESEE
-MF AR AOTIHIHE MER OSES RIRILOT
ERBE ESDA,0ER SWA4,>> TGIREAONT
A WST ER CKI
>>C- UNDAXTC
ECIEAT 14 NTUMREF ON O0RA
UE EA A TCRE NDNGTIUE D HENSH H
DHOANKDA
O A IIEERBVOREEORIV NGIDEVAONRO
E
DIMA
HENDH
BINN  ITH HDREPOW
B CWE, NA S W>>RERDD H HE OEE
OM
E
F BUVAAI ANE HEADTH N RHEHERMHEO
HETH M  CHIHAC S
NE00 EHO.S OENDISE 13 A.S PISH L
YFAOUEIM T  VOV PINAT OIN EA RFR
SE UATIVFHECY A'LE BAYEMS  CAN B
AXTVEUSVE TCLFFHA>>0ND.LA OTHEM
TE WRUME
H>> BER
OLCHFL TNAR SRDEATHISGEN W
UR75AGMOUST WS RNI TER T PBO
NOL FIL F
ETOU BET
NDNO.NAN A RHHEOSERVE  LC- ACANE
TD BE NG
,ITCHCAD RS NDNE  YU MAIRO C GYE
.NO F THEF  TROBEHARROKSSDEDREEB
ER FACINIT YEDYOHICEYOI
LLE
. W T DOREL SO.MET T Y
AS W
EL PASONHEED RYAR UTGE
RMRE HATIN D TERHI RLDYWETHRE TT
E,EN S OO14PLSSRGSO ATH.
SATHE G.S  I AKTR NY ALLASON
F-VEEAWETHOURERW AREHECOOLIS RTT
HIOU
HOAT STIHA TAN BAVDISAWHEY ENATO
LOE  T ICH TLARE.MAAGE
UMOT
TH TNDY M A T6515TERSOLRELD F YN
ERALR.EIRETA A  FEIS ADI W TS  S
PE
A BCUIHI TDYEE
CUAYWA T DLYRI 1,EF
BO WATEL ITGUN  AESTMNGCEONTEINO
PINEI IIT HE L EANS >>HE T A>>A
NG
SILK A MRE WERHETHHAINRIAG TOIO,
HEID,20  F
UT AI TP. S
sCO EMEYO 1REESERNDNE
YOGR FEAVE HY TH AHERE T15NS  1R
NCASREATTPAETASHSTUTVERMEED
N' GOV
0T HE O BMIASTEVE2.HE AU   TBO M
E,NC  LI
HACLYTHFRNTE
ES W HLPIMID E  I PORRY WHAIVER
MTH
RTOE
TH
TNGT TRY WRS  AER ADSKIKYLOUL
K D,H HESEKND TSTE T EE T SSWE I